so Frankie last time I spoke to you you
had retired yes that was it you were
never getting back on a horse competitiv
again and yet here I find you in
Hollywood Frankie's gone to Hollywood go
why did you change your mind so
basically I um when I started this year
no sorry last year uh I thought well I'm
going to be 5503 on a stop at a top
obviously we talked about this before
you know watching the World Cups you on
the bench and I thought well I want to
stop but then people remember that I was
good I don't want to stop that you know
I can't get a ride and then I I said
well I give myself a year I want to say
goodbye to everyone all the countries
that I've been including my own Italian
country and then when I started um I
started winning and then I thought well
this is not going to carry on and then I
kept on winning I kept on winning I got
to about August and just couldn't stop
winning and I I started having regrets
thinking you know am I ready to stop you
know I'm still u in demand but because I
made such a big deal that I was going to
stop and everybody else made such a big
deal the greatest farewell tour since
SRA he kept coming back yeah including
including a lifesty statue unveiled by
Queen Camila
Alaska but then uh you know I have to
leave with myself and I thought well I'm
not ready to stop because I'm still
doing so well but I kind of run out of
avenues because it would have been
foolish to
to say ible to carry it on in in England
after what I said so I only had one
option to come here in
California where I like very much and uh
it just give me a little bit extra time
to get out of my system it's a it's a
stunning racetrack I mean I've had a
home in La for a long time I've never
been here you come here in the morning
it's early only you would get me out of
bed this early and you come and you the
sun was coming up and the Magical scene
of the Santa and e a track it's really
it's it's a magical place it's amazing
I'll be honest with you it is probably
the one of the best looking tracks in
the world with the mountains in the
backdrop uh the track itself is set in a
beautiful piece of land you got this
massive palm trees in the middle of it
uh yeah I mean the the the the light I
uh I mean if if that doesn't take your
breath away no other tracks will and uh
every morning when I come here I feel
like blessed to be be able to you know
enjoy my last bit to my career in such a
beautiful place interestingly at the
very start of your career you did come
here and you did a couple of years maybe
was I did four Winters here I came here
when I was 16 as a illegal worker I came
here on a on a tourist visa and U I mean
the first couple of weeks I go into the
track without getting caught and then
eventually I uh I got caught by security
so I had to use other entrances to get
in I mean most of the people are trying
to get out I was trying to get in but it
was a a great place to come to learn
from the very best you know I remember
Bill schum one of the Legends one of the
alltime great if not the greatest yeah
what was he like H it's a a man of a few
words but it was very tiny but uh a tiny
feet tiny was Tiny was uh less than 100
pounds and U you know he just watched
him right it was Majestic he had that
touch you know he had those just run for
him and and uh yeah I so I did four
Winters here and uh to learn from the
best and then I took uh what I learned
to Europe and I became very successful
and finally enough 36 years I'm I'm back
to where I started when I've spoken to
you we've known each other a long time
uh about the the hard reality of being a
jockey yeah the amount of injuries you
sustain and this is not even jump stuff
this is just flat racing talk me through
the injuries you've had over the years
well first of all um you know we go
extra fast you know we go over 40 m hour
and you know we we we actually about six
foot off the ground so and we raise
inches to each other so you have any
padding at all or no we have little
little pading but there not because
obviously weight is a big issue so you
can't you can't put a arm like a hammer
around you because he weighs and uh so
one little mistake can uh
end up in an accident and and when you
when you go that fast and that speed you
break uh you know we were talking about
I mean I'm I feel like one of the
Blessed ones I did you know you I broke
my ancle twice both of my elbows I broke
my collarbone I BR my shoulder uh ribs
fingers and I feel like you know I'm
actually I did all right really yeah
there's a lot of people in my sport that
that that that broke a lot more uh I
mean when you start this job
the the smell the speed the adrenaline
the crowd the excitement gets you sucked
into this sport you never feel or think
about the danger you know I mean if you
knew where you were going to fall you
wouldn't do it because is dangerous but
but what I said to you just now the the
the the highs overpower the laws of
getting injured and and and messing
yourself up you know like I said when
you what was the toughest injury you had
uh tough injuries I mean they're all
tough you know because what was the
hardest to get back from well uh
shoulder well I brought my uncle that
took took a long time because obviously
you need your uncle to to to balance in
the steups shoulder again that that that
fixed quickly but then the pain is was
there for a year uh you know every inju
is is bad because like every Sportsman
will tell you we always try to come back
earlier than he should have
because you we don't want to miss out
you know because the longer you stay off
then you know you you in danger of
missing out on on a good how much you've
had 3,000 yeah winners you've had three
decades of of racing about that yeah
it's incredible stat 30 30 this is my
37th year can you imagine how much of
that percentage wise have you spent in
some form of
pain uh you get used to it I I can't
really don't know much percent if you
were
guessing I would say a quarter of it
really yeah a quarter of my career you
know then you always had some sort
something yes but you you don't think
like that because you know the the is
always a g dangling carrot it's always a
big race coming up is always that chance
that you will win a big race somewhere
and that kind of is the best best
painkiller in the world the other really
tough physical demand of of racing is
your weight yes what is your fighting
weight what's your best weight would you
say I uh in America here I ride um at uh
118b what is equivalent of the Aon six
in in English Pounds about half a Morgan
yes uh I would say my body weight be a
stor than that i' probably be about 910
if I eat a norm more life but uh so what
do you have to do to hit that that RAC
uh basically I train myself not to eat
bad things for the last 30 years average
day what what would you I don't eat
bread I don't need junk food uh I have a
little snack in the morning and just try
to have one meal in the evening uh
mainly uh
protein uh salads fish chicken you know
I don't eat meat very often but it
depends on people uh but you know I you
know I won't be lying to you I sometimes
have a piece of chocolate or you know
probably have one b past every three
months uh you know I train every day to
keep my way down uh you know it is it's
a lifestyle you know it's a it's a it's
a lifestyle it's a big sacrifice it's a
big sacrifice and uh 37 years yeah and I
I you know it sounds funny but I even
when I do have time off uh I always go
and reach for a chicken c a salad you
never see me eat a burger or really cuz
I I think my body now can't take it
anymore can you drink alcohol or not I
like wine because I'm Italian yes but in
moderation but like I said my body is
now used to not having those kind of uh
rich food that uh yeah I I I'll be
honest with you I now then finishing my
career I'm finding it easier maybe
because you know uh I have a routine I
don't go out as much uh that's why
California suits me I mean everything
shuts up here right it does yeah but uh
you know I guess 10 years ago and I
wanted to go out every night did not
suited me but you've talked before about
being Bimi at various stages I did 10
years of in Bic yes uh guess in my
between my 30s and 40s and you would
throw up before racis yeah I would have
a meid a night and throw up or sometimes
I would have a big breakfast and throw
up but I didn't do it because I wanted
to do it I did it because you know the
skill doesn't lie it was a a way of
lifestyle that chose to to have you know
no different to I guess mothers have the
same problems or teenage kids they joies
I think you said you do you you had to
use laxatives diuretic everything I
tried everything I tried U uh diuretic
pills
laxatives uh made myself sick I remember
driving car with a sweatsuit with the
heaters on you know I you know you try
you try extremer things in in your job
because you have to do the weight I
don't think anybody
has done what I've done and people St
people still do it they actually choose
that because they like it it's because
they have to do the weight simple as
that I mean it's it's a phys physically
very hard sport yes I don't think most
people realize until they Listen to
Someone Like You talk about it just how
physically demanding it is first of all
like we we explain is is the diet then
you have to have you have to be ultra
fit because in a space of a day you can
rise six or eight races right and you
know you you handling 1,000 pound worth
of absolute explosive flesh I mean these
horses are powerful and you have to
control them and uh so that's physical
demand the diet and then also the
injuries you know what I mean when you
do have the injuries uh you have to
goope with that so overall I mean I
didn't sell it very well right if you
want to become a Jo well I think it's
the reality of it right that is the
reality but you know we we do it because
you know we addicted to it that feeling
I mean I watched the tape last night
preparing for this interview when you
went through the card at waraska and won
all seven races only time anyone's ever
done that and the last race you're on a
horse where you don't think you got a
chance of winning what's the name of the
horse rest right and you're you're
you're leading but Pat edre is coming
behind you you can you can hear his Whip
and you think he's going to be he's
going to be and there somehow you get a
second win with this horse and it and it
wins that moment when you cross the line
and knew you've gone through the card at
Alaska what is that like what's that
feeling like well you get that feeling
of basically it's like um everything
when you cross that line everything just
goes in slow motions you just you know
you you know you're just Galloping on
top of the source you got time to look
at a crowd and everybody's going
ballistic they only last for a few
seconds and you back to real
life and it's you know is in a way is
very selfish is it's an emotion that
nobody can you can ever explain I mean
like I said never mind the dangers but
the you know the crowd the smell the
speed the excitement and and and you
cross that line and the Euphoria what
hits you is incredible that's and that's
why you get addicted and that's why I do
it because and is that why you can't
really give it up yet yes you know
obviously it'd be much easier if I if I
didn't get a chance of winning that many
or you don't need the money right I mean
you made you've made enough money not to
worry about that yeah but you do it
because you love it because
otherwise it's hard to let go you know I
I I go great sympathies for other
Sportsmen that that that to stop I mean
I stopped for a week and I didn't like
it well I've got friend Sports Friends
Freddy flintoff is one who had to give
up you know really just in his early 30s
lot of people is because of injuries
right it wasn't his case but you know 30
or something I had to give up this
career and he was a he was a legend in
England abely um I've met lots of people
like that where they're in sports where
they can't go on as long as you can the
good thing about your sport is you can
keep going yeah I mean I'm 53 this is
year 37 what is a nerd of I mean back in
the day 50 was the magical number if you
get to 50 you were like a superman but
nowadays with the
nutritionist way Al uh we learned from
the old boys what they did wrong a lot
of people smoked back in the day uh I
mean life expand is much longer Roger
fedra still amazing player 40 so even
football is not Christian
ronaldo9 so you know um you know I'm I'm
I know 53 sounds a big number but I
still feel that I'm still competitive
even though that I'm racing with jocky
30 years younger than well how many of
them actually weren't even alive when
you started I would say 70% really it's
crazy right that's that's nuts it's
crazy and how do they treat you uh the
it's funny because now you we call it
the the the jocks room right I love this
jockey room this is this is amazing bit
of History this place is timeless you
can come here at 16 or 53 we all the
same age it's only when you step out of
there that you feel your age but when
you come here it's great bant we all
treat each other the same and if you do
something wrong everybody jumps on you
um it's probably one of the odest place
to let go when you're a professional
like me what advice do you give the
young whipper snappers uh but the advice
is number one number rule is you're
going to love the horse it's no point do
something that you know the horse is the
most important thing you got to love it
and if you love The Horse technique you
can learn uh you know and experience
will come what about what about this
because I always think in any sport what
differentiates the good from the Great
great is is a mental thing absolutely
absolutely and that comes with
experience um nobody is born with that
great
mindset uh experiences of Life uh
circumstances
emotions uh you know when when you're
young you have emotions but you don't
know how to deal with them right uh so
as you get older you deal with emotions
with the when you know when you get B
when you're nervous you know I'm I'm no
different to anyone even in my age
I still get a dry mouth you know uh if I
ride a favorite a big race I'm the first
one to tell you of course I'm nervous
but nervous is good because now I know
how to deal with it but you can't teach
that that you you got to learn it you've
also got to have in your sport in
particular a ferocious work ethic right
you have to yeah you can't wing it can
you no you can't uh physically you got
to be ultra fit you got to put your own
work and then but also you got to have
that Natural Touch you know you you can
work as much you you can but you got
sometimes you got to let things happen
you got to use your Natural Instincts
you cannot predict how the race is going
to go or no strike can predict how he's
going to score but you got to use your
natural ability and that's a difference
from you know being a normal joy to be a
superstar you know and that's applies
the same to any other sport you know
when you see Geniuses like Messi uh you
know they they do things that I don't
think they who do you most admire in
other sports oh I admire all the sports
you know obviously I'm a big football
supporter uh I even adire the boxers the
the were fatting they have to put up uh
the rugby players you know I don't know
too much about Cricket but you know
sometimes you see uh like like the World
Cup this year was you know I know India
got beat but was an amazing game you
know I like all this great sport
sporting events and as you know the
Super Bowl is coming up that's be
another amazing event remember talking
to Michael Phelps the swimmer and I
asked him it's just before the 2012
Olympics and I said what makes you the
greatest swimmer ever and he said well
why don't you go back and ask all my
rivals have you ever gone five
consecutive years without a day off
training because they they've all never
done that yeah yeah I did and I said
what what made you do that he said well
I wanted to be the best yeah ever and I
worked out if I did seven days a week
they all do six so over a year I would
do 52 days more training so when we
stood up in a big event the Olympics the
world championships and we all stood
around I would look left and look right
and they all knew I was going to win
because I'd done 52 more days training
than them every year but he had the
mental Edge on them before he started
but the sacrifice that goes with it is
enormous as he said he missed you know
weddings and christenings and funerals
and birthdays and everything you miss
everything all you know all sports have
to do that I mean I this year I was on
the track Christmas Day and I was riding
uh New Year's Eve a New Year's Day
really and you know I sacrific having
Christmas with the children but they not
children anymore because I told them
said listen you know you're 18 plus now
I'm sure that you don't believe in Santa
cluz anymore and I'm sure I just I'm
sure you can cope Christmas without me
but you know it was important to me
because here we start Boxing Day the 26
it it was important to me to start at
the start you know I didn't want to come
here 3 days later you know that would
give a bad example to people want to put
me up trainers and owners so I'm going
to start like everybody else so that
means sacrifice Christmas but you know
you do things like that you know because
uh you know when you are a sportsman and
you're a family man you you're the
pillar of everybody you know if you fail
everybody fails and so you have to think
like that and uh that's what inspires me
to be the best you've had two two
moments in your life since you became a
professional jockey which could have
ended everything one your own fault and
I'll come to that in a moment this the
first one though was the plane crash
which is really one of those moments in
your life where it was a light aircraft
you were going from one race course to
another the pilot very sadly died you
were with your great friend and manager
Ray Cochran at the time you both managed
to get out um just before it all went up
in in flames
what do you remember about what happened
that day what I remember about um in a
nutshell you know I can explain it um
it'll take hours but basically on take
off something went
wrong plane went down and what were you
feeling as it went down what I feel when
I was down I I looked at Ray and as I
was staring as the ground was
approaching I didn't have have time to
scream and I was just disappointed that
I was going to die I I was thinking to
myself I'm 29 years old I just had a six
month child why are you taking me now it
was just disappointed why now you know I
I I got so much through forward in life
that's all I felt you really thought you
were about to die that's it no two
question about it and some
miracle what was the landing like some
miracle well the the wing of the plane
CLI this Bank were made the plane
rotate anyway never never mind that so
it was just like an enormous speed in
the washing machine in don't of what
happened can you remember that yeah I
remember the impact and then uh I
obviously my skin on my forehead went
all the way back so my blood was pouring
in front of my face and I was in a state
of concussion I guess where I had 18 180
Vision I could see the two planes two
engines on fire and I saw the pilot
inched down in
front but I couldn't move I was just
paralyzed I just couldn't I knew that to
get out but I could not move and then
Ray gave me a nudge was next to me and
he he kind of w me up and I realized
that I broke my leg and when I went to
get out you know it was a six-seater
twin engine the the plane was like in
bits the the door didn't exist anymore
luckily for us the luggage door was just
in the back of the seat was half open
and as I crawled out I realized that a
broken leg Ray pushed me out then he
crawled out and he dragged me away from
here to the end of the room and then and
he was concerned that the so much fuel
was on the plane that he could all go up
and then he tried he took his jacket off
and he tried to go back for the pile and
the plane exploded and he was burned
from at to toe uh and he was you know I
couldn't I could e him yelling of anger
because he couldn't get the pilot out so
you
know it was a trauma for me uh I lost my
good friend my pilot I was lucky twice
lucky to be alive the crash and lucky to
be alive then Ray got me out of that
plane I couldn't be burned alive you
know it took me 17 years to get back on
a plane uh did you really yeah I mean I
was scared and even now again how how
long between you getting out of the
wreckage and it going up was it seconds
really seconds so you were seconds from
just yeah from I mean imagine the the
two Wings playing full a few seconds so
Ray saved your life he did yeah yeah and
save my life and I owe him my life and I
when he when he had big neck problems
after the crash so I told him to quit
racing and he became my manager for 20
years so do you ever talk about it
together i r never talked about it we
talked about it 20 years after really
yeah we had a to together uh raay is a
very deep man he you know yeah never
talked about it and now going person
always talked about he never he kept it
to himself and yeah I mean
it's you can't
explain what we been
through uh and there is ways to deal
with it perhaps I should have SE help
but and I had good family around me and
you know my little I am I shouldn't have
be here there we go it's an
extraordinary story imagine imagine yeah
twice and I read that um that later you
were thinking you were 29 you were
thinking you'd always wanted as an
ambition young Italian right to buy a
Ferrari right and you just thought well
what am I waiting for right I could have
died just B Ferrari I said to myself
when I get to 30 if I got enough money I
love to get a ferar AR being Italian and
at 29 and a half after I got out of the
hospital as soon as I could walk a
little bit I went to get myself one I
thought you know right and you know it
did change my life in you know I would
say I was if that didn't happen I
probably would have been more successful
in my career but you know I become why
because you spent more time with family
yeah I was more focused and I didn't I
was tonal Vision but after that you know
family you know I've got five children
yeah uh you know I juggle life and rid
in and try to get the bo of both world
and you know a lot of times you think
you know why should you get upset you
know after what happened to me a lot of
things really don't really matter you
know the other thing that could have
ended everything for you professionally
was when you tested positive for cocaine
in 2012 and you really struggled for
quite a long time 18 months to get
another good ride you thought maybe
that's it that was a self-inflicted
wound when you look back at that I mean
obviously fortunately you had a a sort
of Sav you who came along and picked you
up and said right I'm gonna I'm G to
back you so basically yeah oh look I was
silly boy you know went out took some
drugs got tested a week later and it was
in my system you know I wasn't doing it
because it was R it was a more Rec
recreational and yeah quite rightly so I
admitted it I got six months
band took my family out of school we
went around the world because you
obviously they were getting bullied they
were getting picked out at school you
know you know Paparazzi outside my house
how did that make you feel that you
brought that on everyone not great uh I
think the biggest disappointment is
telling my own parents I how did they
react not great my par my dad being old
fashioned um kids you know that thought
was quite funny having Paparazzi outside
there to smuggle me in and out the car
with a
blanket uh we had a good time together
around the world and um you know I
served my time I did my six months I
came back and I thought well
everything's going to be on on kidori
come back but you know obviously nobody
would touch me you know you know for
some reason you said you felt like a
leper was like yeah I mean I took it you
know it took me I just couldn't get
right for for about a year and then um
yeah I got to a point a year later I
couldn't
see the light at the end of the tunnel I
thought well I've got no other choice
you know I can't I can't get any
business so maybe have to look to do
something else maybe in what would you
have done if you hadn't been just proba
maybe going to the
media uh but you know I wasn't ready to
quit you know you know how are you
feeling in that Wilderness period I felt
terrible I felt terrible and you know
and then uh the worst thing was you know
even my wife started doubting me you
know she said to me the famous word show
me how good you are really you know we
one day you know we were struggling to
pay bills and things were going bad bad
and we all end up in an argument and um
and she R you know all your life you're
telling me how good you are look at us
now we can't pay bills just show me how
good you are and that wow that that's a
moment and that was like you know
somebody shot me in the Heart Right
coming from my own wife and that really
got me fired right up and I just said
nothing and I put my head down and
persisted and carried on carried on
and 0 months later a year later I goes
and win the Epson D on Golden Horn and
with a massive party home few drinks
with friends that feeling when he
crossed the line and he won the do oh
that was amazing the feeling but but the
feeling was when I got home and we did
the party did you say to your wife
that's how good I am so basically when
everybody left the house and we were
sitting there and I said do you remember
what you said to me here ago I said
that's it I said don't ask me again
I've done it now so that was it so you
know what did she say I she said that at
the time I needed something like that to
to probably did to make me believe or to
give me a push and yeah I mean those
famous words show me how good you are
yeah they they imprinted in my house
trust me that's an amazing story mad but
you know I
think you know sometimes we'll need
someone to to to touch that nerve yes
you know and fire you up again and
that's at the time that's what I needed
and you know oh better person than your
own wife who knows me so well to to just
you know and she said you know I just
needed to say that and and it worked how
important has she been Catherine to you
well you know she's been with me 30
years I mean I feel sorry for that I
brought her through this crazy life you
know never mind self-inflicting stupid
things that I've done playing Crashers
nearly kill myself
every day worri that I could end up in
hospital when I ride you know it must be
a worry for for a woman to marri
somebody like me but she St with me we
had some amazing times together and you
know she's been so good to me do you
remember when you proposed to it I did
yeah I was in scalini one of my favorite
Italian restur in London and uh yeah it
was a nice afternoon in London and I got
a money and I remember every in the
restaurant in the restaurant everybody
stood up and clapped yeah really was
yeah it was sweet did you have a ring I
did have the ring yes yeah of course and
I also I was told because I'm not
English I was told I had to go and see
the father then I went to see cath's Dad
the night before and I got a full
lecture from his father and how did you
sell yourself to him well I said listen
I came to ask the hand of your daughter
and he sat me down I said listen I said
before you start this she's going to
finish her studies you going to look
after her give me a proper wash down
proper goody English wash down but yeah
great yeah yeah I'm you know five kids
what's the secret to a lasting marriage
do you think uh I think we don't leave
in each other's
pocket um she lets me get on with what I
have to do she's been Ultra busy with
children uh and we meet in the middle
you know we have our own things that we
like and you know she just me free range
to be what I have to be you know uh you
know I'm sure man of the races that's
what I am and he just lets me do you
know what I have to do but is very
important that to have that backing the
other family that you've been very
attached to is the royal family yeah who
love you and you love them um
particularly you had an amazing
relationship with her majesty the Queen
the late great Queen when did you first
meet her do you remember I could have
said this I probably I'm not
I knew over 30 years back in the days
when I was in my early 20s I used to
Rite for the trainer C Ian baling and
Ian Bal had most of the Queen's horses
and uh so that's how that's how matter
and uh you know even 30 years that I met
her every time I met
her nervous wreck she had this horor but
she always had the ability to make you
feel to make you feel uh good uh um so
I'll tell you a funny story I went I
went a big
race 15 years ago and it was a Sunday so
after racing I I had the big party it
was a lovely spring day and I left all
the doors open I had dogs and 200 people
turned up we had an amazing party and I
woke up the next day and um house was
destroyed full of bottles and and I
realized I lost one of my dogs but she
had a
tag and it was was a message on the
answer machine and the message said I we
found your dog please call us back on
this number and the lady who found the
dog was uh Caroline
Warren the queen racing manager's wife
so I ran Caroline said hi Caroline sorry
but I heard that you have my dog can I
come and collect it and she said listen
if you come this
evening uh the Queen's coming to New
Market to see the horses in the morning
so you can say hi to the queen and pick
up the dog I mean great idea so my
wife's in the in the courtyard she's
cleaning the ponies and I opened the
window said honey I found the dog and
she said where is the dog oh the Queen's
got it she said dumb be silly no no I'm
swear the Queen's got it going to pick
it up tonight so my daughter got dressed
up we went to get the
dog and um and there she was she was
having a Jen tonic next to to the fire
and I had a j and tonic with her and she
spent 20 minutes talk talking to my
daughter about about ponies and about
school and then uh they let the dog out
the dog ran towards me and peed in the
Persian
carpet in front of the queen in front of
the queen of John Warren and uh the
queen started laughing and John got
really red faed got really upset in that
moment I got sced out said uh we got to
have dinner now you better go Frank you
byebye but the queen was just creased
laughing she was so funny to be around
she also had an amazing knowledge of
horse racing this wasn't someone who did
it as like a little mild hobby she she
knew everything right yes 60 years
listen it's incredible she wrote when
she was in the 90s around wind Windsor
Park and yeah of course she bred horses
for six years you rode 50 winners for it
yeah over 50 winners yeah amazing did it
always feel a little bit extra special
when you won a race for the queen but
look when you when you got the other
colors in the peg like that there was a
already excitement you know and you know
amazing place she Royal you know I mean
she she was racing uh family started
racing 300 years ago King Charles the
first 350 years ago so racing is in the
blood and she had so much knowledge and
she loved that she absolutely loved
racing didn't you used to occasionally
try a cut me accent with it
we you know she used to I tried but
didn't go very well but what was it you
said to her how
are but I said what did she say she said
to me I'm still
here usually she bow see your majesty
but I kind of froze and I went how are
you and she went I'm still here but she
was she
was what would you talk about just
generally when you saw her everything
she like to hear the gossip about the
inside God gosip who you know you know
Rich trainer was going out with all yeah
all the the juicy gossip yes yeah yeah
she very interested about that and you
know she she just loved to be around
racing
people when she died it was a huge
moment for the country you're you're a
kind of angelized Italian you're Italian
but you've obviously spent a lot of time
in England what what was that moment
like for you how did you hear that she
died well I saw the last time I saw was
a Royal Ascot and she obviously quite
fra she couldn't get up open and down
the stairs and they made the little room
next to the paddock so she could watch
the racing and to a point an took the
horse inside the little booth to to show
the horse and yeah and you know for you
know you always feel she's
Immortal and when it does happen is a
shock you know because I felt she was
Immortal and I remember we were meant to
race a Don castday night and uh race got
cancelled quite rightly
so yeah and it just how did you
hear I think we just heard on the radio
I think from a phone call and uh yeah
just I felt quite emotional when I yeah
it just comes a shock real shock like I
said because you know always felt that
she was Immortal and you know we Mo we
lost a great person great mon Monarch
well a great person and you know I'm the
first one to say that I met her for 30
years you know she really touched me the
way she made you feel and the way she
was and you know I'm not the only one I
mean I would say millions of people feel
the same but actually very few would
have had the access you did yeah all
that kind of relationship because she
loved horse raiding racing almost as
much as anything else in their life yeah
you know probably saw other side of it I
mean a lot of times I saw her in in
events and she would make a detour to
find somebody into raceing because she
kind find that exciting uh yeah I'm I'm
I'm very lucky and and also the new king
you know I I was you know I I never
really met King Char like this year you
know he came Royal ASCO five days
straight to a point on day five I
actually I was invited to have lunch a
wind a castle on day five and I did the
the the ride on the
carriage and he turned around to me and
said um you know my my my mom would have
been proud to see me racing five days
straight so I think we got him
interested in austr and and it's good
because it's nice to keep the tradition
and especially now that we are in this
Joy room I feel very proud that it's
beginning to enjoy enjoy racing you
recently went to the Jungle in Australia
comp I'm a celebrity you were the first
to be kicked out of there which I think
is probably a blessing I don't know why
you went me too me too like at least you
haven't got to stay in there with these
was it even remotely an enjoyable
experience or is it just as awful as I
imagin is well it was exactly what I
thought you know you got to have a a
mindset and if you got in your arm
what any weaknesses is going to find you
you know um is atile where we are you
you sleep in a
bench uh you eat rice and
beans the dongy or the toilet I used to
call it is all on the ground more or
less um the humidity and the loneliness
you know because you there by yourself
okay you with other people you go no
watch no contact from the outside world
so it's stuff did you like that or was
it weird it was weird you know I didn't
I'm not say I I I liked it it was an
experience that I did I met some good
people I did it because I wanted to
challenge myself and I achieved that my
worst scenario would have been been in
because I'm claustrophobic being in a
coffin with snakes guess what happened
they put me in a coffin with snakes of
course and uh so I I I conquered that
fear and yeah it was an
you know I'm you know if I said it was
fun it wasn't it wasn't how did you feel
about being the first to to leave uh I
like you said I was pleased I found it
completely incable I don't really know
what was televised on TV because I was
there 24 hours and they cut it down into
one hour and talking to the people
outside the you know BR interested the
politics Nigel farage or people arguing
you know I'm not I'm not a fighter I'm a
lover
I I had a great time in there but they
they never a showed all the fun times
than I had you know they were more
interested about what Nigel farage or
Britney Spear sister were going to say
course they W they they didn't care what
a jocky were going to say so but you
know it was an experience and I've done
it I take that box and that's it you
also were named in the top six nominees
for the sports person of the year on the
BBC very prestigious and you've won it
uh many years ago uh to be in the top
six when you're 53 years old of the top
six Sports people in Britain it's pretty
incredible I think the only one um born
when I started riding was to abroad all
the others weren even born it's quite
scary yeah amazing obviously this late
in my career and and also racing is not
a football Cricket tennis rugby sport
followed or or like the Olympic so it's
great privilege for me to be nominated
and also for my sport you know because I
promote myself I also like to promote my
sport how did you feel about a member of
the women's lionesses team winning given
they actually hadn't had a very good
year yeah they lost the World Cup they
didn't qualify for the Olympics and they
still won it having won it the year
before maybe I should lose a bit more to
get to get in the top three should it
only go to people who've actually won
something that year I I I I I I saw your
podcast you did and I I I I I agree with
you but you know even St abroad I mean
amazing this last year he's won
everything and and he didn't with it
either but is what
people uh watch or like so but I'm are
we becoming Frankie a country which has
moved from celebrating great Champions
and winners to now we we almost
celebrate losing that's what it feels to
me we've moved as a society from a
really the underdog yeah but I don't
it's not even the underdog just okay
you've lost we're going to give you a
participation prce right well perhaps
perhaps so you know I'm must say all the
six nominees including myself I mean you
know we all had done something great but
uh you know it's it's down to the public
to decide and um and I'm I'm not bitter
like I said already been nominated I
feel like a winner what's been the
greatest Accolade for you you've won so
many things what's the one that meant
the most to you well I'll be honest with
you uh my biggest achievement obviously
winning seven races in a day but overall
you know being on top of my game for 30
years thought you know it's hard enough
to do it for 10 so to do it for 30 I can
see here and be proud of it that uh you
know I'm
still competitive at 53 so how long do
you think you can realistically continue
for how long is a piece of string as
long as you're going to be like sonara
just keep retiring and coming back well
no listen I'm not going to I feel like
uh this is this is my last bit of my
career here in California I enjoy it you
know if you can get one or two more
years out of it be great but in my sport
you never know uh you know uh fingers
crossed then I don't have any accident
and I still compe it R off and uh if I
can get like I said in one or two years
be great beae do you like America love
it what what do you like about it
compared I like the
lifestyle uh I don't I think Europe as a
jockey you we travel so much and I come
to a point that I'm sick and tired of
sit on the motorway stocking traffic we
uh in the America you're more based in
one place you don't travel as much uh I
feel a bit Freer than I am in England I
don't sound spoiled but okay I'm famous
on the racetrack but I can step out out
paint my to Nails wear a minis skirt
nobody cares are you doing that no I
don't do that I'm just telling you
that's the difference right in in
England you on Europe you get judged
what you wear or what you do you always
looking yourself behind that's the
difference then I find a bit more uh
relaxing you have a very competitive dad
he was a champion jockey many times
himself gave you a hard time when you
were young still is still gives you a
hard time to it still is it still tells
me what should should have done and you
know which Gap I should have took really
obviously my dad was a jockey
professional jockey very successful very
successful so I I can't pull a wall over
his eyes because you know exactly when I
did right or you were quite from what
I've read you were quite a sort of shy
retiring young kid right you weren't
this charismatic AB Thunderball and your
first race your dad gave you a pony you
had a first race you came last and you
fell off after the finishing that's
right when that happened did you ever
imagine in your wild wildest thoughts
that you might end up as one of the
great jockies in history no absolutely
not I was a quiet
nice uh non- amiti person then my dad
kicked me out of home he didn't kick me
out he send me to England but it was
like being kicked out because I I
couldn't speak English I'm going to a
different country I was getting bullied
the the weather the food everything else
was different and uh but
that that man me up and also I didn't
want to embarrass my dad so it made me
work extra hard and then the writing
started I realized that oh maybe I'm
quite good and then it snowed out of my
control I started winning and then from
a little ball it became a big ball and
then I became what I am now but I never
started with the ambition that I was
going to be great when you ride now you
a little part of your still trying to
prove a point to your dad oh yes oh yeah
yeah my dad's I don't think my daddy's
ever said well done really yeah no no
he's never I don't think even when you
won the seven races it might just as a
grunt now when even when you went
through the C when I won the seventh
races I ask her guess what I turned
around to my mom he said oh I think the
teletex is broken because Frankie is 107
he couldn't believe it he didn't believe
it but did he congratulate no he didn't
no no no are you serious course I'm
serious that's dad that's hilarious yeah
he's like yeah doesn't
you know if he says nothing then means
well
done yeah are you like that with your
kids completely the opposite spoil I
give him everything uh yeah complete the
opposite to my dad but you know but
despite despite the way he is your
generation do you think that that that
work ethic that will to win the
competitive spirit all of that do you
think in the end you've got a lot of
your success because of the way your dad
was yeah absolutely that's why I I'm
I'm I stop now asking him because I
always end up arguing with him I says
Dad you push me you brainwash me to
become a champion you know what about
especially my sport if I free through my
career I would have broke my knee and
stopped riding I would have felt inside
would have felt a loser you know and he
turns out says well I can't answer that
look you're a champion about what you
know he never gave a thought about
something beyond your control that could
happen but you know but isn't that a
champion mentality yeah but it's it's
probably is but you know I got to some
way going to thank him to make me think
like that but it's something that I
can't do to my children maybe because
I'm new generation maybe because I'm
soft I just can't do it but you know
what was your mother what she been like
with you sorry has your mother been
different my mom she's uh like mothers
you know loves me my my my dad's super
tough what was your mother's proudest
moment do you think maybe when you got
the M MBE from the queen um listen my
mom she's you proud you know everything
that do you know she's typical mama she
just wants to C me and feed me and you
know uh my my dad yeah I look my my dad
is proud too you obviously doesn't sure
but but you know like like what you said
that point if he wasn't for him pushing
me I would never be here because I
didn't have it in me have you pointed
out to him that you've now continued for
two years longer than him uh no I don't
want to R it in listen no the dad is 82
um luckily still with me uh his brain is
good obviously he's a bit frea but you
know I'm I I guess I'm keeping him Alive
by him watching me still ride so it's
good it's good that a lovely story
Frankie about you is the the seventh
ride you had when you went through the
car you ended up keeping that horse as a
pet so basically fjam also won the seven
he end up going jump racing and U and I
think he had a pelvis injury so it was
going to end up God knows so I rang the
trainer and I said could I please buy of
him and I took him home and became my
pet for 20 years he was he lived in the
field and he was the hor who made me
famous he was the horse who won the
seventh race and you know I gave him a
good life till the very end and he you
know he passed away one day in the field
it didn't suffer it just you know it
lived a rip old age till it was about 25
that's a lovely story well I owe it to
him you right he made me famous finally
if I could have the power to let you
relive any race in your entire career on
any horse again right now you can do it
right out on that track which one would
you
choose very hard to say um only have
have
won I would say because it's fresh in my
mind this year's Champion Stakes my
everl last ride in England on my
retirement day the day that the queen
and V my statue I win the Champions
Stakes I couldn't wrote it don't I don't
think no even Hollywood could have rot
the finale so I would say that P how
would you like to be remembered if you
could write your own Tombstone here lies
Frankie Dori he I've had fun along the
way um uh and U yeah I was uh you know
i' I've I've did my job with a smile in
my face and we're both Arsenal fans
absolutely we're going through a very
tough period right now I I know we
haven't I can't fix that we haven't won
the Premier League since 2004 I know
you're a miracle worker do you see any
Prospect we can do it this year yeah we
still got three weeks if we buy a nice
Center forward I think weekend we got to
have a winner a striker come on a killer
come on three weeks left come on we got
plenty of time to buy one Frankie great
to see you in Hollywood thank you peace
all the
best